only two for oh okay wow that's a crazy
looking Med kick maybe down strong I
imagine look how much meter were you
already buil yeah look at that
interesting back dash has canel out of a
back dash it looked like so there's a
Revenge meter right up at the
top after lightning kick no Z dice for
that kick gets in the upper
cut ex ready to go super
maybe stay away away maybe trying to
work on a
super but look they check out the
Revenge bars at the top what okay he he
the he pop the mirer his hands are
electric now yes but they're not
electric anymore trying to find like the
bar that oh no that used that the ex oh
you're right okay yeah you're
right oh
yeah that was the meter super and just
knocks ch right through the
wall
[Music]
okay really oh
jug oh com means business now get the
throw he's turned it
on
's
a m getting ripped
upost the first round the first
[Music]
time Focus time to go oh here we go L
versus
lightning bra are still glowing
[Music]
blue nothing afterwards though oh big
jump in
nothing oh so you can
just oh
dang she she still she still has the the
noodles on
[Music]
head there oh no it's still there she
got a permanent hat
[Music]
now
oh why would you do
that super is kind of
D oh that's
it